common birds like the pigeon shown here  exhibit grace and precision in flight  that far exceeds our best robotic  capabilities inspired by these maneuvers  we have built an autonomous aircraft  capable of fast accurate and repeatable  flight  utilizing motion capture for feedback  control we demonstrate this system by  flying through a gap that is smaller  than the aircraft's wing span  accurate control in these flight regimes  is difficult because of the complex air  flow induced at high angles of attack we  capture 120 frames per second onboard  video for use in studying machine vision  here we demonstrate avoiding vertical  and horizontal obstacles  finally we showed these videos in real  time